salut les cookies oui les intros sens de
pire en pire mais je vous rappelle que
c'est vous qui décidez dans les
commentaires de quel sera mon intro de
la semaine prochaine alors cette semaine
on va essayer de résoudre cette pyramide
c'est pas moi qui vais la défaire c'est
le oui parce que j'ai peur quand la d 10
ans je puisse comprendre comment allez
faites donc il va il a [ __ ] à plat et
moi le but ça valait d'essayer de la
remettre en place et de parler
correctement
pour rappel la tournée continue je serai
un spectacle ce samedi à dijon grèce
quelques places mercredi prochain à
lausanne du 22 au 24 à mulhouse et aussi
en dédicace à boulogne et à colmar vous
avez toutes les infos le lien est dans
la description c'est parti la pyramide
c'est juste un niveau 10 ou le fait
gagner si j'arrive de seulement elle
résonne évidemment double dit comment à
la fin de la vidéo comme d'habitude loïc
est ce que tu peux me démonter ce casse
tête
je ne regarderai pas je vais démonter
val-des-monts touba a démonté c'est pas
du haut rhin sylvain donc sinon je moi
je le vis dès jeudi j'ai rêvé monde et
je regarde faire je crois que tu as trop
fini castex et j'étais dumazy voilà
bonne soirée donc je viens juste de me
rendre compte d'un truc c'est que j'ai
pas du tout pris le temps de l'observer
avant quand même un minimum dire que je
me souviens juste qui a le truc rouge là
c'est au milieu c'est au dessus
et je me souviens de quoi d'autre de ces
crénelés tout autour et qu'il y avait
une petite alternance dans la pyramide
avec le blanc et le fond c
c'est archi trop con allez bon courage
aux caisses des partis
alors je découvre en même temps qu'elle
y croit c'est à paris qu'il peut pas
être enlevée au centre mais ça ok et
donc c'est un peu crime s'était un peu
calmée comme ça point ok on y va ça tu
vois par exemple quand ça se chevauchent
comme ça je pense que c'est fait pour
être posée comme ça presque lacroix a
une bonne carte su en faire sa part
alice a l'air d'être un principe une
sorte de petit pont comme ça et ça
allait terminer comme ça donc si l'as
roma temps normal mais j'ai un trou ici
en fait qui n'est pas comblé je vous
fais voir attention en sarthe n'a pas
comblé ici il faudrait un truc comble le
trou là qu'est ce qui pourrait vous
mettre un peu les prix ça flacon m
as atteint 6,6 fois que cette vidéo ça
va être la vidéo d asi pénates à
maintenant indécis et batipart qui reste
un trou non remplies à la fin titre
titre hi et a bien compris le concept
des titres c'est que ça très très des
concepts je faisais que ça quand j'étais
au lycée ses revenus après à la mode
c'est reparti et robin lui de tenir en
fait n'être qu'un truc comme ça puisque
c'est la seule manière c'est la seule
manière pour que ça ça ne sais pas si
vous voulez que je dise cookies ou
cookies précisé la prononciation que
vous voulez à chaque fois dans les
commentaires en vrai je sais que c'est
un truc de mai modérateur de la dream
team des motos mais ils n'ont toujours
pas expliqué le débat donc je suis dans
le foot c'est plus le temps passe en
fait que j'avançais plus je et plus je
recule ainsi va la vie
lent plus j'avançais plus j'oublie
comment était le casse tête au départ
parce qu'on a des pièces identiques
en fait j'ai envie d'avoir l'impression
d'avancer alors que les trier les pièces
plantes
[Musique]
voilà comme ça je suis bien organisés et
je préviens d'avancé
ok ça va être relou avec comment relou
m comment ça va être au loup on
s'appelle max à six parce que comme il y
avait un nom mais pourquoi on n'a pas
pris de photos au départ me servais ça
tue les rires c'est vrai
c'est pas cool je sais pas la vidéo tuer
c'est vrai bon alors que je peux faire
[Applaudissements]
et quel enfer du coup il ya un truc qui
veulent pas quoi bon ça ça fait quand
même un côté qui rampent là il faut
avancer pour essayer des choses je vais
essayer d'aboutir un truc déjà et ça
tout le temps de réfléchir
tout ce qui va à priori il y aura peu de
[Musique]
l'enfer là j'ai l'impression qu'on est
reparti sur bin oui jamais en fait je
commençais à comprendre pourquoi c'est
un niveau 10 voix ça vient
parce que c'est dur ça se trouve des
stands où on a peut-être un poisson
qu'il est qu'il est bien d'aller est
finie state ça se voit un peu là non ça
va qu'est ce que c'est agaçant
il découle est très agaçant j'ai déjà
dit qu'il était très agaçant sûr c'est
pour ça je me dis que le préciser c'est
pas une mauvaise chose en soi
non mais tu fais bien parce que sinon on
croit tu sais ce qu'on prend je te le
dire mot ce qu'on croit on croit que
c'est pas agaçant alors qu'en vrai que
je te dise cet agaçant et six guides
assemblée sera dans sa tête je sais pas
on voit là on voit bien sûr la caméra du
dessus les formes des pièces
dans ta tête tu dis avec ses formes la
vie doit continuer le cac mid créneau en
prenant en compte le fait qu'il ya ces
deux barres fixes
c'est scandaleux
ça doit même pas exister en fait ça ça
par contre c'est pas mal du tout ce que
vient de faire de m alors ici encore
quand tu l'as des faits est ce qu'il ya
un endroit où il y avait un trou sk à
ses deux tubes pour former une pyramide
plein ou est ce qu'il ya des endroits
creux j'ai vu ta tête de gay je tâtais
de s'arrêter je pense sincèrement d'une
manière définitive
un espèce de refus de l'information un
profit de la question ceux ci on a droit
de faire des trous et ne pas mettre
toujours la même couleur
moi je suis chaud pour le finir oui on
fait le poste n'est pas un placement de
produire mais ça je suis vraiment a dit
donc le quai aller s'acheter une boisson
que j'étais réellement parce que je
boycotte
et moi j'ai passé tout le temps août où
il est allé faire les courses et c'est
de réfléchir je crois que j'ai inventé
je crois même que j'ai les trois quarts
et je me dise si j'ai les trois quarts
le dernier quart mais j'ai perdu
ensemble et j'ai failli abandonner losc
c'est grave
qu'est ce que c'est alors mais on est
d'accord avec les alors bout d'un centre
de foires
non je ne suis pas du tout sur mon
pantalon tu juges pas musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que moi je me suis dit quoi je me
suis dit que lui je voulais pas le
coller à côté d'un blanc mais j'ai pas
vu moi au départ ce que ça donnait ok
donc si ça se trouve il ya moyen de
combien ça marche pas comme l'histoire
bien comme ça
[Musique]
voilà non seulement elle aussi un trou à
l'intérieur attentes
si je mets du millas
ah là aussi un trou en fait ya des trous
dedans y aurait un trou là mais on
trouve là parce que la pyramide donc les
applaudissements c'était quatre ans mène
d'ailleurs il y en a plus - ici un peu à
plat de foul la new soul un délire enfin
c'était ses shows en fait les choix à
faire mais alors après une fois qu'on
réussit à le résoudre
ça veut dire techniquement j'essaie en
speed intimés train d'accélérer mais
c'est le gars que je démonte j'ai pas
d'engagement c'est à dire que si le
démon de capable de leur faire assez
vite puisque quand tu galères sur un
casse-tête compliqué en temps normal
tu te rappelles à peu près de sa bouche
biologie pour le remonter peut-être
[Musique]
voilà j'avais envie de prendre cette
pause un petit peu eh bien écoutez ainsi
s'achève cette vidéo après ça se
mémorisent bien aussi bien que si on
utilise une memory boxe je le rappelle
qu'elle est sortie je vous mets le lien
vers la vidéo de justice
oui c'est mon nouveau projet for all
tout retenir c'est la méthode que
j'utilise donc une quinzaine d'années
ici vous avez le dernier casque quand je
vous mets le dernier casse tête de la
dernière fois là je vous mets une autre
vidéo
c'est un casse-tête du mentalisme
n'hésitez pas à aller voir ça quand vous
trouvez que d'être casse tête alors
qu'il n'a que 4 ce mois-ci sur 15 vidéos
mais du coup voilà ça existe encore
c'est là ici vous pouvez vous abonner
pour s'appliquer à très bientôt
ciao